it's the holiday season and it's back in
full swing for the first time since the
pandemic began but the looming threat of
another coronavirus outbreak could spoil
the festive spirit
I think our lives are more precious than
the festivities we have to prioritize it
all comes down to people's awareness
India had rolled back most restrictions
after the rate of infection slowed in
the past few months most people have
stopped wearing masks even in crowded
places such as markets but the outbreak
in China and uptick in several other
countries has prompted fares another
wave could be devastating for an
underserved Healthcare System and a
struggling economy
some pandemic protocols have returned
Travelers need to be fully vaccinated
against covid-19 and thermal screenings
will take place at airports the
government says about two percent of
international Travelers are being tested
upon arrival and some tourist
attractions are testing visitors before
they enter parliamentarians are wearing
masks and encouraging people to do the
same Karnataka state in Southern India
has made face coverings compulsory
indoors
we have asked States to become more
Vigilant and increase genome sequencing
of all positive cases if we have a new
variant in India we can identify it in
advance because of the festive season
and New Year we have asked states to ask
people to use masks and sanitizers and
encourage social distancing
there's also renewed focus on vaccines
while 90 of eligible people are fully
vaccinated against covid-19 only a
quarter have received a booster shot
epidemiologists say immunization is
crucial to managing a virus that's here
to stay I do not think India needs to
panic at all because the situation in
India is very different from that in
China
in India we have had prior exposure to
the virus in various forms including to
Omicron early in January this year and
we have acquired a fair amount of
immunity because of the exposure to
different versions of the virus
while the government is asking people
not to Panic it's preparing more
guidelines for the holiday season
several hospitals Nationwide will
conduct drills next week to ensure
they're ready to handle an influx of
patients should the need
ariseera New Delhi